to find somebody to fill Philly's shoes
in the film to find an actress to fill
that role that missing quite something
something quite difficult because you're
the real to rap gonna be able to act
it's gonna be able to mote yeah
absolutely I mean I hate that ya know
the the it we couldn't make the movie
without her I mean it was that was one
of the things that when we when we had
when we finished with the script we knew
that if we couldn't find the actress
that could pull it off it wouldn't work
so we you know we scoured the earth the
entire globe and we found Xena
but no GI you know all in all
seriousness she came in and she did an
amazing audition and then she was busted
to like a impromptu riot a rap and we
were like okay cool thank you for coming
and then right she walked out were like
that's her that's really we know we got
her you know its color give her a couple
hours but we call her right away like
they scared me visas because they were
like okay great and I was like oh okay
and then we called you like come in late
right listen we we really we don't need
to go any further we know that you know
you're a Philly brown would love you do
it obviously that's super exciting to
get that role but it also is it a bit
scary a bit much pressure to carry a
movie in that way I mean your
character's name is a title of the film
Wow yeah I mean I got the pressure now I
didn't think about it already no um you
know it was a huge blessing so grateful
a dream come true because it was
something I've always you know I know
every actress
every actor just you know longs for an
opportunity to be able to spread their
wings and show the world their their art
and their soul pretty much because
that's what I put on the screen and to
be able to do filly Brown was a
tremendous blessing because it's such an
awesome role she's so awesome and and
then on top of that it's terrifying to
be around at regimes almost and Lou
Diamond Phillips and Amelia Rivera and
jenny rivera and then be there for me
for for like you said
Billy brown and that's like I hope I
don't let them down I hope I don't let
them down and you know looking back on
it I think I played it off pretty cool
but I was I was probably pretty
terrified terrified as I am now as my
father judges my performance so I guess
it never ends right Michael why don't
you tell us a bit about the inspiration
behind the film
yeah well Youssef my directing partner
isn't here so he could speak a lot more
about that because really the the seed
of the idea was his and he saw a beat
poet in the performance and was inspired
by that and the script you know he had
the script for about three years three
or four years and it was aware of it cuz
we're friends and I've directed my
features and he has to but when he came
to me well he said hey we have a
breakthrough and we've we're gonna do a
hip hop but it's a female MC which
hasn't been done that's like all it's
amazing and then was great as it's
really the stories about as a family
drama in the world of hip-hop and so I
was I would go right in with him and
what was really inspiring was that it
was third generation lets you know like
kids like us that don't really speak a
lot of Spanish you know but you know and
you know are sort of like merit very
American and it's sort of our world you
know and to be able to bring that like
the next sort of like the the stories of
the next generations or the next two
generations is real it was really
exciting Gina how important is it for
you to be a role model I guess for for
like young Latinos so um I'm surprised
that I haven't talked about it yet on
this on this panel of awesome media but
that's the reason why I became an artist
it's the reason why I want to be Who I
am all the time
gracious humble accepting of every
blessing that comes my way because when
I was growing up I didn't have role
models on screen that weren't playing
the hooker prostitute pregnant teen and
you know and except for one
almost I know your dad your dad no but
he's not a girl I know he's not a girl
yeah Godfather for life but maybe you
know this but but for me it was always
looking up to the screen and wanting to
see my face wanting to see a normal girl
wanting to see a normal girl that's
doing normal things that has a normal
story because I sure did you know and I
and I also desire and longed to be able
to change the stereotypes in Hollywood
and cannot continue to perpetuate them
and change the way minorities are viewed
in the media and let little brown babies
everywhere look up at the screen and see
there I am there I am and I'm a doctor
I'm a lawyer or I'm an awesome hip-hop
artists and and I'm normal and I'm just
a girl and I really am a girl in
polkadot you know a multi-talented one
though speaking of which before we let
you go can you spit a little something
for the camera I have a little something
Billie Brown whatever you want filly
Brown superstar status lifestyle lavish
threat games lady savage you've now gone
wild kill you with the smile the world
is all mine check the myspace profile
voice of the people so real like AG like
the new hustla on the block somebody
better call the cops and lights out pull
the plug you should feel me like a thug
the hottest thing in the club a no
fallen in love